We've already talked about how
a benzene ring is very-- let
me draw a better looking benzene
ring than that-- that
a benzene ring is very stable,
because it's aromatic.
That these electrons in these
pi orbitals that form these
double bonds, they're actually
just not in this double bond,
they can keep swapping.
This one can go here.
This one can go there.
That one can go there.
Actually, they don't
go back and forth.
They actually just completely
go around the entire ring.
And when a molecule is aromatic,
it stabilizes it.
But we've seen examples of
aromatic, or actually, in
particular, we've seen examples
of benzene rings that
have other things bumping off
of them, whether they're
halides or whether they're OH
groups, and what we want to do
in this video is think about how
that might happen, how do
things get added on
to a benzene ring.
We're going to learn about
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
Let me write that down.
Electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
And you might say, well, Sal,
you just said you're adding
things to the ring.
But the reality is that there's
six hydrogens here.
There's one hydrogen, two
hydrogens, three hydrogens,
four hydrogens, five hydrogens
and six hydrogens.
They're always there.
If you don't draw them, they
are implicitly there.
So what we're actually doing,
when you add a chlorine or a
bromine or an OH group, it's
actually replacing one of
these hydrogens.
That's why it is substitution.
It's aromatic, because we're
dealing with a benzene ring.
We're dealing with an aromatic
molecule, and we're going to
see that we need a really strong
electrophile in order
to do this.
Let's think about this
how this will happen.
Before I do that, let me just
copy and paste this, because I
don't want to have
to redraw this.
Let me just copy it,
just like that.
So let's say we have a really
strong electrophile.
And I'll give you particular
cases in the next few videos,
so you can better visualize
what a really strong
electrophile is.
But just from the word itself,
electrophile, you could
imagine it's something
that loves electrons.
It wants electrons really,
really, really,
really, really badly.
And usually, it has
a positive charge.
So it wants electrons badly.
And actually, let me
make it very clear.
Instead of saying it wants
electrons badly, because when
you're talking about
electrophiles or nucleophiles,
you're actually talking about
how good something is
reacting, you're not actually
talking about the actual
energies involved.
Let me put it a different way:
good at getting electrons.
Really, really, really,
really, really
good at getting electrons.
So what would happen?
We already said this is
already pretty stable.
These guys, these electrons,
these pi electrons can
circulate all around.
If it bumps just in the right
way to something that's really
good at getting electrons, what
might happen-- let's say
we have this electron
right here.
The way we've drawn it, it's
on this carbon right here.
Obviously, the carbon is just
at the intersection.
I never drew the carbon.
But if this electrophile,
which is really good at
getting electrons, bumps in
just the right way, this
electron can go to that
electrophile.
And then it would be left with--
so let me copy and
paste our original molecule.
So then what would
we be left with?
So we no longer have this
bond right here.
It has now been bonded
to the electrophile.
Let me make it clear.
We had this electron
right here.
That electron is still on this
carbon right over here at this
intersection, but the other end
of it, the other electron,
has now been given to the
electrophile, the thing that's
good at getting them.
So the other side has been given
to this electrophile.
This electrophile now
gained an electron.
So it had a positive charge,
now it will be neutral.
And once again, I'll show you
a particular, or several
particular cases of this
in the next few videos.
Let me just make it clear.
So this bond, you could now view
it as being this bond.
Now, this carbon right over
here, this lost an electron.
So if it lost an electron,
it will now
have a positive charge.
Now, this is hard to do to a
resonance-stabilized molecule,
to a benzene ring.
So that, once again, and I said,
and I'm being a little
bit repetitive, this has
to be a very good
electrophile to do it.
But once this is there, this
is a actually relatively
stable carbocation.
The reason why it is, it's only
a secondary carbocation,
but it's actually a
resonance-stabilized
carbocation because this
electron right
can be given to that.
If this electron goes there,
then it would look like this.
Let me redraw it.
I'll draw the resonance
structures quickly.
You have your hydrogen.
You have your electrophile.
That's not an electrophile
anymore, but you have that E
that's now been added.
You have that hydrogen.
You have a double bond here.
Let me draw a little
bit neater.
You have this hydrogen.
You have this hydrogen, this
hydrogen and this hydrogen.
What I said is, this
is stabilized.
So an electron here can actually
jump over here.
So if this electron jumps over
here, the double bond is now
over there If that goes over
there like that, the double
bond is now over here.
Now this guy lost his electron
and it would
have a positive charge.
And then that is resonance
stabilized.
It can either go back to this
guy, or this electron over
here can jump over there.
Let me redraw the whole
thing over again.
Let me draw all the hydrogens.
This right here, you have
the E and the hydrogen.
You have a hydrogen here,
hydrogen here, hydrogen here,
hydrogen here.
And normally you don't worry
about the hydrogens, but one
of the hydrogens is going to
be nabbed later on in this
mechanism, so I want to draw all
the hydrogens just so you
know that they are there.
But as I said, this is
resonance stabilized.
If this electron right here
jumps over there, then this
double bond is now
this double bond.
And now this guy over here lost
an electron, so it would
have a positive charge.
And again, once you had this
double bond up here, this
double bond up there is
that double bond.
So we can go back and
forth between these.
The electrons are just swishing
around the ring.
So it's not going to be maybe as
great as the situation that
we had when we had a nice
benzene ring that was
completely aromatic.
The electrons can just go around
the p-orbitals, around
and around the ring, stabilize
the structure, but this is
still a relatively stable
carbocation, because the
electrons can move around.
You can kind of view it as a
positive charge that gets
dispersed between this carbon,
this carbon, and that carbon
over there.
As I said, it's still not
a great situation.
The molecule wants to go back to
being aromatic, wants to go
to that really stable state.
And the way it can go back to
that really stable state is
somehow an electron can be
added to this thing.
And the way that an electron can
be added to this thing is,
if we have some base flying
around, and that base nabs
this proton, this proton right
here that's on the same carbon
as where the electrophile
is attached.
So if this base nabs a proton,
so it just nabs the hydrogen
nucleus, then that electron that
the hydrogen had, that
electron-- let me do that
in a different color.
That electron that the hydrogen
had right over there
could then be returned to
this carbon up there.
And maybe that makes it
a little confusing
when I cross lines.
It can be returned to that
carbon right there.
So what would it look
like after that?
After that it would
look like this.
Let me draw my-- so if that
happened, and we drew it in
yellow, we have our
six-carbon ring.
Let me draw all the hydrogens.
What did I do that in?
It likes like a slightly green
color I did that in.
So I have all the hydrogens
on that ring.
Now, I have to be careful.
This hydrogen right there, just
the nucleus of it, got
nabbed by this base.
So that hydrogen has now been
nabbed by the base.
This electron right
here has now been
given to this hydrogen.
So that electron has now been
given to this hydrogen, and
then the other electron in the
pair is still with the base.
So now this is the conjugate
acid of the base.
It has gained a proton.
And on this carbon, right here,
we just have what was
the electrophile.
And I'll do the same colors,
just to make it clear.
What was the electrophile
right over there, this
bond is this bond.
And then finally, we had-- and
I'll color code it here just
to make it clear.
We had this double bond here,
which is this double bond
right over here.
We had this double bond.
We had this double bond, which
is that double bond there.
And then this electron gets
returned to this top carbon
right here.
So that electron-- let me make
it very, very clear.
So the bond and that
electron are
returned to that top carbon.
So that we have the bond and
that electron returned to that
top carbon.
That top carbon is now
going to be neutral.
And once again, we are
resonance stabilized.
One thing I forgot, just to make
the charge stabilized,
maybe this base had a negative
charge to begin with.
It didn't have to.
But if this base did have a
negative charge to begin with,
it now gave an electron
to the hydrogen,
so it is now neutral.
And this should make sense
because before we had a plus
charge and a negative charge,
and then when everything
reacted, everything
is neutral again.
The total net charge is zero.
But this is the electrophilic
aromatic substitution.
We substituted one
of the hydrogens.
We substituted this hydrogen
right here with this
electrophile, or what was
previously an electrophile,
but then once it got an
electron, it's just kind of a
group that is now on
the benzene ring.
And by going through this little
convoluted process, we
finally got to another aromatic
molecule that now has
this E group on it.
In the next video, I'll show
you this with particular
examples of electrophiles
and bases.